THERE ARE INDEED SOME
SHENANIGANS, I WOULD SAY.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
THANK YOU, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IT’S A GO PRESIDENT WRAPPING UP
YET ANOTHER HUGE RALLY, THIS
TIME IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THOUSANDS LINING UP IN THIS CASE
IN THE RAIN EARLIER TODAY FOR
HOURS IN WHAT IS A TRUE
TESTAMENT TO THE PRESIDENT’S
RESILIENCE AND THE RAPID
ADVANCEMENT OF AMERICAN
THERAPEUTICS, DONALD TRUMP IS
NOW CRISSCROSSING THE COUNTRY
ONLY DAYS AFTER HIS VERY SWIFT
RECOVERY FROM COVID-19.
INDEED HE DOESN’T SAY I WANT YOU
TO HAVE THE EXACT SAME
THERAPEUTICS I HAVE AND I WILL
GIVE IT TO EVERY AMERICAN THAT
NEEDS IT FOR FREE SO THAT THEY
CAN GET THE FDA APPROVAL.
HOW COME THE MEDIA DIDN’T COVER
THAT?
MEANWHILE, HIS OPPONENT
JOE BIDEN CAN BARELY CROSS THE
DELAWARE STATE LINE WITHOUT
BECOMING CONFUSED AND SLEEPY AND
IRRITATED.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN
DR. RONNIE JACKSON IS SOUNDING
THE ALARM, AS MOST AMERICANS CAN
SEE, ABOUT BIDEN ’US, WELL,
MENTAL FITNESS FOR OFFICE.
WE WILL GET HIS TAKE STRAIGHT
AHEAD TONIGHT.
ALSO, SPEAKER PELOSI HAD A
PUBLIC MELTDOWN ON FAKE NEWS CNN
EARLIER TODAY AND SHE DOESN’T
WANT TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY SHE’S BLOCKING A
SECOND COVID-19 STIMULUS
PACKAGE.
WE WILL PLAY YOU THE LOW LIGHTS
OF HER MELTDOWN, BUT FIRST WE
BEGIN TONIGHT, JUDGE AMY CONEY
BARRETT IS WELL ON HER WAY NOW
TO BECOMING THE NEWEST JUSTICE
OF THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT.
SHE RAN CIRCLES AROUND THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS AT TODAY’S
HEARING.
SHE MADE THEM FRANKLY LOOK
STUPID, UNPREPARED, DESPERATE.
SHE EXPOSED THE ABSOLUTE HATRED
THAT NOW DEFINES THIS NEW
RADICAL, INSANE, AND EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
SHE DID IT WITH A CALM,
UNFLAPPABLE DEMEANOR AND A SOLID
COMMAND OF FACTS WITHOUT A
SINGLE NOTE IN FRONT OF HER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES THE CONSTITUTION GIVE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES THE AUTHORITY TO
UNILATERALLY DELAY A GENERAL
ELECTION UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
CIRCUMSTANCES?
DOES FEDERAL LAW?
>> IF I GIVE OFF-THE-CUFF
ANSWERS, THEN I WOULD BE
BASICALLY A LEGAL PUNDIT, AND I
DON’T THINK WE WANT JUDGES TO BE
LEGAL PUNDIT’S.
I THINK WE WANT JUDGES TO
APPROACH CASES THOUGHTFULLY AND
WITH AN OPEN MIND.
>> IS ROE A SUPER PRESIDENT?
>> HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE SUPER
PRESIDENT?
>> ACTUALLY, I MIGHT HAVE
THOUGHT SOMEDAY I WOULD BE
SITTING IN THE CHAIR -- ARE NOT,
I’M APPEAR.
>> PEOPLE YOU SUPER PRESIDENT
DIFFERENTLY.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO SAY THAT
ROE WAS CORRECTLY DECIDED?
BECAUSE THAT’S REALLY THE
ESSENCE OF THE QUESTION HERE.
>> WELL, SENATOR, AS I’VE SAID,
TO OTHERS OF YOUR COLLEAGUES IN
RESPONSE TO QUESTIONING, THAT
IT’S INCONSISTENT WITH THE
DUTIES OF A SITTING JUDGE AND
THEREFORE HAS BEEN THE PRACTICE
OF EVERY NOMINEE THAT SAT IN THE
SEAT PERFORMING TO TAKE
POSITIONS ON CASES THAT THE
COURT HAS DECIDED IN THE PAST.
>> SINCE YOU BECAME A LEGAL
ADULT, HAVE YOU EVER MADE
UNWANTED REQUESTS FOR FAVORS OR
COMMITTED ANY VERBAL, PHYSICAL
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT OF ANY
NATURE?
>> NO.
>> HAVE EVER FACED DISCIPLINE OR
ENTERED SETTLEMENT RELATED TO
THIS KIND OF CONDUCT?
>> NO, SENATOR.
>> I WANT TO JUST ASK YOU VERY
SIMPLY, I IMAGINE IT WILL GIVE
YOU A VERY SHORT RESOLUTE
ANSWER, BUT YOU CONDEMN WHITES
OF PHARMACY, CORRECT?
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
I’M GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU SAID
THAT.
I WISH OUR PRESIDENT WOULD SAY
THAT SO RESOLUTELY UNEQUIVOCALLY
AS WELL.
>> Sean: HE’S ONLY SAT IN A
MILLION TIMES AND WE PLAYED IN A
MILLION TIMES.
JUDGE AMY CONEY BARRETT OR
JUDGE ACB AS SHE IS NOW BEING
CALLED, HER TRACK RECORD IS
IMPECCABLE.
SHE’S MORE QUALIFIED TO SERVE ON
THE HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND
THEN, WELL, A LOT OF SITTING
JUSTICES NOW, SO NOW
SENATOR SPARTACUS AND HIS
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES, THEY ARE
ENGAGING IN LITTLE MORE THAN
PERFORMANCE THEATER, A BABY
TEMPER TANTRUM HERE AND THERE,
SOMETHING THEY ARE FRANKLY VERY
FAMILIAR WITH.
AND THAT’S WHY WE SAW ALL OF THE
PROPS TODAY.
IN FACT, FAR LEFT
SENATOR SHELDON WHITEHOUSE WAS
SO BUSY WITH HIS LARGE CARDBOARD
PRINTS THAT HE FORGOT TO ASK
JUDGE AMY CONEY BARRETT A SINGLE
QUESTION FOR 30 STRAIGHT MINUTES
MINUTES.
AND BY CONTRAST, WELL, JUDGE ACB
HAD NO PROPS, NO PREPARED NOTES
WHATSOEVER.
NOTHING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MOST OF US HAVE MULTIPLE
NOTES AND NOTEBOOKS AND BOOKS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT IN FRONT OF
US.
CAN YOU HOLD UP WHAT YOU’VE BEEN
REFERRING TO IN ANSWERING OUR
QUESTIONS?
IS THERE ANYTHING ON IT?
>> THE LETTERHEAD THAT SAYS
UNITED STATES SENATE.
>> THAT’S IMPRESSIVE.
>> Sean: DEMOCRATS COMPLETELY
OUTMATCHED, COMPLETELY
OUTCLASSED BUT THAT WON’T STOP
THEM FROM DOING ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING IMAGINABLE TO BLOCK
JUDGE BARRETT’S CONFIRMATION.
WE KNOW THE GAME PLAN, WE ALL
KNOW WHAT THEY DID TO
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND HIS
FAMILY.
THEY TRIED TO RUIN THIS MAN’S
LIFE AND FOREVER DESTROY HIS
REPUTATION AND WHAT WAS NOTHING
BUT A POLITICALLY CALCULATED AND
COORDINATED HIT JOB.
THEY RIPPED AWAY HIS PERCEPTION
OF INNOCENCE, ALL DUE PROCESS.
THEY MADE RECKLESS, BASELESS,
FALSE ACCUSATIONS ONE AFTER
ANOTHER.
THEY PUT THIS COUNTRY THROUGH
HELL, ALL IN THEIR ATTEMPT TO
UPEND HIS CONFIRMATION.
WATCH THIS.
>> JUDGE KAVANAUGH, YOU SHOULD
NOT BE SERVING IN THIS BUILDING
AS A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS YOUR WORST
NIGHTMARE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE
DR. FORD, WHO BRAVELY COMES
FORWARD, NEED TO BE HEARD, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
IF THEY NEED BE BELIEVED.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE MEN
IN THIS COUNTRY, JUST SHUT UP
AND STEP UP.
>> LET’S LOOK AT BEACH WEEK
RALPH CLUB BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR
CLUB.
>> THAT PROBABLY REFERS TO
THROWING UP.
>> DRINKING IS ONE THING, BUT
THE CONCERN IS ABOUT
TRUTHFULNESS AND IN YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY, YOU SAID SOMETIMES
YOU HAD TOO MANY DRINKS.
IT WAS THERE EVER A TIME WHEN
YOU DRANK SO MUCH THAT YOU
COULDN’T REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
OR PART OF WHAT HAPPENED THE
NIGHT BEFORE?
>> Sean: SO WILL THEY EVER
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TREATMENT OF
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, APOLOGIZE TO
HIS FAMILY?
WILL THEY EVER APOLOGIZE FOR THE
HIGH-TECH LYNCHING -- YOU
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID TO
JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS.
WILL THEY EVER APOLOGIZE TO THE
FAMILY OF ROBERT BORK AND THE
FALSE ACCUSATIONS MADE AGAINST
HIM?
OF COURSE NOT.
FOR DEMOCRATS, NOTHING IS EVER
OFF THE TABLE.
LIES, SMEARS, SLANDER.
IT’S ALL A MEANS TO AN END.
BY THE WAY, BUCKLE UP AND
PREPARE FOR THE WORST.